[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à bruxelles
ravi de vous retrouver pour 30 minutes
de décryptage de l'actualité européenne
dans la seconde partie de l'émission
direction la hongrie viktor orban n'en
finit plus d'inquiéter l'europe dans sa
dérive autoritaire chasse aux migrants
référendum stop bruxelles fermeture
d'université et mise au pas de la presse
et des ong comment les européens
peuvent-ils faire entendre raison au
premier ministre hongrois ce sera notre
eu des bas mais d'abord l'actualité les
scandales de harcèlements sexuels
révélés dans le monde entier dans la
foulée de la sphère harvey wang xin
n'ont pas fini d'ébranler médias
politiques et institutions le parlement
européen n'est pas en reste
ici aussi les révélations sont
nombreuses avant d'en discuter tout à
l'heure avec mes invités j'ai le plaisir
de recevoir jeanne portée aux jeunes
bonjour vengeurs vous êtes l'assistante
parlementaire du député socialiste
edouard martin qu'on recevra tout à
l'heure et depuis votre arrivée au
parlement en 2014 dans le sillage de son
élection ici vous compilez dans un
carnet tous les témoignages on vous
avait eu vent sur des questions
notamment de harcèlement sexuel
d'agression sexuelle voire plus loin de
viol comment est-ce que vous est venue
l'idée de compiler tout ça dans ce petit
carnet et bien oui donc depuis juin 2014
je tiens ce petit carnet de notes et de
comportement et de paroles sexistes qui
ont été soit vue soient entendus par un
certain nombre de mes collègues soient
que j'ai pu vivre personnellement c'est
venu assez naturellement et de manière
assez spontané j'ai pas découvert la
défense des droits des femmes en
arrivant parlement européen mais je suis
arrivé j'étais tout jeune étudiante
enfin d'étudiantes pardon j'avais 24 ans
et j'ai travaillé dans une commission
parlementaire qui était encore à large
majorité une commission plutôt tenu par
des hommes la commission industrie et je
me suis dit voilà j'ai été confronté à
un premier comportement qui pour moi est
inapproprié vous avez sur un pc ou d'un
comportement à l'entraînement déplacer
exacte de la part d'un député dans
députés
de nationalité allemande et je me suis
dit ça c'est pas approprié sur sur mon
lieu de travail ça me met mal à l'aise
ça me gêne ça me choque donc je vais
consignes et un certain nombre de
d'expérience
toutes ces expériences pour ne pas m'y
habituer parce que je pense que le plus
grand des dangers en fait c'est de
s'habituer à ce type de comportement et
à se dire un passé en entend souvent
c'est de la drague lourdingue où c'est
comme ça en politique ou à partir du
moment où il ya des relations de pouvoir
c'est comme ça ou alors c'est des
pratiques culturelles différents tous et
des générations d'hommes des années
60-70 différentes et donc tout ça ce
n'était pas acceptable pour moi et je me
suis dis donc je vais consignés pour
pamiers habitués pour savoir y répondre
mais le parlement a mis en place un
comité spécial contre le harcèlement
dans l'institution vous aviez eu vent de
l'existence de ce comité ou pas alors
moi je quand j'ai signé mon contrat de
travail en juillet 2014 ce comité
n'existait pas encore il a été mise en
place à l'automne 2014
je dois dire que moi je ne connaissais
pas l'existence de ce côté mais ce
comité il a le mérite d'exister
ça se fait connaître dans d'autres voilà
exactement et parce que quand on compare
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat on
voit qu'il n'y a pas de comité qui doit
statuer et instruire des cas de
harcèlement de manière générale ce
comité il est là pour le harcèlement
moral et le harcèlement sexuel donc dans
son ensemble on voit aujourd'hui qu'il
n'y a pas eu de plainte devant ce comité
pour harcèlement sexuel alors que
lorsqu'on regarde les différents
sondages etc
on voit que c'est quand même 50 %
peut-être des femmes qui seraient
touchés par des comportements
inappropriés ou par du harcèlement
sexuel donc ce comité il a le mérite
d'exister maintenant il faut
perfectionner voilà vous lire les
témoignages que vous avez recueillis
c'est globalement quoi c'est du
harcèlement sexuel c'est des propos
déplacés graveleux de la drague lourde
comme vous m'avez voire beaucoup plus il
ya toute une vie à toute une panoplie
évidemment et c'est pour ça que quand on
parle de harcèlement sexuel c'est
toujours difficile pour des femmes de se
dire bah tiens ça c'est du harcèlement
sexuel
et donc c'est punissable ou alors ça
c'est juste une tentative de séduction
dont je ne souhaite pas pour ça que
parfois la différence est assez mince et
il faudrait quand même des exemples
précis pour dire bah ça c'est du
harcèlement sexuel et on vous informe
que vous avez des droits et que vous
pouvez défendu donc moi dans mon carnet
il ya toute une panoplie le commentaire
sexisme et les commentaires sexistes
quand il arrive à répétition de la même
personne ça devient sa deuxième
seulement sexuelle est d'ailleurs le
harcèlement sexuel n'y a pas forcément
non plus l'objectif à la nécessité
d'être répété ça peut même être une fois
et de manière ponctuelle
c'est pour ça que il ya un flou
juridique quand même sur cette question
de harcèlement sexuel qu'il faut qu'il
faut trancher et que les femmes et les
hommes doivent connaître pour savoir
aussi se défendre mais ça va du
commentaires sexistes au harcèlement
sexuel et aux messages reçus en plein
milieu de la nuit par des députés et de
manière répétée à des cas d'agressions
sexuelles parce qu'à partir du moment où
on touche quelqu'un c'est de l'agression
sexuelle est fort heureusement et j'ai
pas eu de connaissance de cas de viols
est en tout cas le carnet n'a pas
consigné de cas de viols mais
effectivement ce sont des rumeurs mais
ces sont des rumeurs qui sont là autant
parler de cas de viols qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous attendez du coup de
l'institution ici au parlement européen
d elisabeth morin-chartier questeur qui
est députée française et qui est en
charge de la question et plus largement
ici au moins il ya une prise de
conscience c'est toujours étonnant de se
dire que ce soit au sénat à l'assemblée
nationale que ce soit en belgique ou en
france pour l'instant rien n'est sorti
est ce que ça vous étonne
alors déjà au niveau du parlement moi je
suis extrêmement content parce que c'est
un environnement qui est constructive
tout le monde a envie d'avancer dans le
dans la même direction et ça c'est
extrêmement positif et ce comité il a le
mérite d'exister on le disait si ça
m'étonne à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat je suis en contact avec les les
collaboratrices qui ont lancé cheikh
collaboratrice il ya déjà quelques
années et elles sont aussi maintenant
dans la tente que quelque chose serait
pas dorment au niveau de l'assemblée
nationale donc de cette attente il faut
qu'on construise quelque chose et je
crois que en tout cas au parlement c'est
c'est bien parti
bon bah écoute et on va en discuter
justement avec les députés que je vais
recevoir dans un instant dont edouard
martin avec qui vous travaillez
karima delli il y a quelques jours
justement suscité beaucoup de débats sur
les réseaux sociaux
après avoir interpellé justement les
parlementaires européens à balayer
devant leur porte
merci jeanne frontières film merci à
vous de ce témoignage et on écoute
karima d'élus avant de retrouver mes
invités il y a deux hommes parmi mes
collaborateurs est ce qu'il m'est arrivé
un jour d'en fermer l'un d'entre eux
dans mon bureau de serre est l'un d'eux
contre un placard ou de leur passé les
fesses dans un ascenseur
jamais jamais de la vie en revanche cela
arrive à tant de femmes ici au parlement
européen
alors il va falloir balayer devant notre
porte
le monde politique est fait par des
hommes pour des hommes et combien
d'entre vous savez combien n'ont rien
dit
face à des tels comportements
inadmissibles le pouvoir de la tan dun
un sentiment d'impunité intolérable il
faut que cela cesse
pas demain maintenant pour toutes les
filles et femmes d'europe
nous devons agir vite faire de la
prévention partout tout le temps
donner plus de moyens injustices former
des services de police parce que chers
collègues la peur et la honte doit
changer de camp
la peur et la honte doivent changer de
camp et pour en débattre
edouard martin bonjour bonjour député
socialiste donc au parlement européen
français en face de vous marrer qui
aurait que je suis ravi de vous recevoir
ginette député conservateur réformiste
et vous venez de pologne
quand vous entendez l'interpellation de
karima delli qui pousse le parlement
européen a balayé devant sa porte
est-ce que cela vous étonne est ce que
vous aviez eu vent edouard martin on a
reçu votre assistante jeanne pontet qui
tient un carnet depuis 2014
vous aviez eu vent donc de ces
comportements vous le saviez bien sûr
que je le savais et bien sûr que j'ai
encouragé mon assistante a effectivement
répertorier les actes d'agression de
harcèlement etc de manière à ce qu'un
jour on puisse effectivement en parler
et le cas où winston nous a donné
l'occasion entre guillemets si je puis
dire de mettre en lumière que ça
n'existe pas uniquement chez les stars
d'hollywood mais ça existe dans tous les
lieux doivent tous les lieux de pouvoir
et y compris au parlement européen hélas
nous ne sommes pas exonérés comme je
l'aï déjà dit je me suis je ne sais pas
si on a plus ou moins qu'ailleurs
néanmoins nous sans que ça existe et
notre devoir et notre responsabilité
collective c'est de se doter d'outils
pour qui mettre un terme à la querelle
que vous êtes d'accord vous aviez
amusant vous aussi de ce genre de
comportement pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a
rien fait avant
je suis à la pilule one pas ce que
j'appelle la présidente a gagné 2,1
formé par le maroc aux personnes
suspectes de cette comportement
intolérable
je pense que le devoir de chaque
fonctionnaire du parlement et
spécialement du président du parlement
informer tout de suite le parquet hier
la police que je ne peux pas comprendre
la réaction du président du parlement
qui a dit il y à la commission pour des
assistants qui parlera les assistants
sont représentés ce n'est pas la
question interne de règlement
parlementaire
ce n'est pas la question des conditions
de travail sur la question de l'acte
criminel
donc je parlerai de viol je ne vais pas
je ne veux pas substituer à
la cour mais il faut informer la police
il faut l'enfermer
la paire club vous êtes d'accord edouard
martin bien sûr que je suis tagliani en
fait s'est dit horrifié par tout ça mais
il ya effectivement un comité spécial
contre le harcèlement qui existe dans
l'institution depuis 2014 selon lui
potentiellement ça suffit voulez vous
l'avait interpellé ça ne vous aura pas
échappé que nous avons dit que si ce
comité a le mérite d'exister
il faut le garder il n'est pas adaptée à
la situation du rayonnement sexuelle et
c'est pour ça que nous avons demandé
nous un audit externe afin qu'ils
viennent voir exactement quelles et
l'amplitude du problème est peut-être
aussi nous aider à améliorer
effectivement les ags réponse sur cette
question ce même et là dessus c'est faut
simplement être conscient mais je sais
que vous le savez c'est que évidemment
qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes
évidemment qu'il ya beaucoup de victimes
qui aimeraient porter plainte mais vous
savez très bien que elles ont des
contrats précaires et sur le simple fait
d'une rupture de confiance
le député peut licencier les assauts
sans assistance comme c'est la bible
seulement et ensuite être utile pour la
prévention un peu pour la laque réaction
il ya une seule réaction informé le
parquet et la police obligations ici on
vit ici on dit sur ceux là dedans martin
dit bien quand on a affaire en fait à
des cas notamment de l'assistante
parlementaire face à leurs députés
il ya des témoignages qui ont été
recueillis par le journal en ligne
politico ou par le sunday times qui sont
quand même extrêmement lourd on parle
quand même de députés qui auraient
possiblement enfin à se masturber devant
leurs assistantes c'est quand même
extrêmement grave
comment dans ces conditions on peut
protéger ces femmes est de faire en
sorte qu'elles ne perdent pas leur
emploi c'est aussi ça on est aussi dans
une question précarité par la réaction
parle à l'action dans l'opinion publique
après l'action ge aviation par des
réactions judiciaire est absolument
nécessaire parce que je pense que le
parlement européen ne pourrait pas
participer dans la conspiration qui
protège la personne qui harcèle la femme
il n'y a pas de conspiration élaborer un
contraire nous sommes en train de
renforcer les outils parce que vous
savez lorsqu'une personne est victime de
harcèlement d'agression sexuelle avant
avant de l'amener à la démarche de
porter plainte
il faut d'abord accueillir s'en sont
ressentis quelles que puissent avoir un
lieu en toute quiétude le plus témoigner
de ce qu'elle a vécu les des psycho
logiquement et ensuite après la baie en
syrie ensuite la conserver en son balai
devant la justice mais en même temps il
faut lui garantir la protection
aujourd'hui le cas n'est pas n'est pas
sur la table on n'a aucune garantie de
la protéger et moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que ça change c'est quand on
revoit le statut des attachés
parlementaires c'est à dire dans ces cas
là il faudrait faire comme pour les
fonctionnaires européens
c'est pendant toute la durée du mandat
on puisse lui garantir un emploi ça
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à nous suivre
là tu voleras bien sûr bien sûr je pense
qu'il faut faire tous total jean le cam
mais avec responsabilité de personnes
coupables bien sûr le parlement européen
s'est saisi de cette question la parole
se libère
elisabeth morin-chartier questeur chargé
de la question députée française s'est
félicité dans un tweet que la parole
justement se libère mais on voit bien
que dans les parlements nationaux dans
le reste de l'europe c'est quelque chose
qui pour l'instant n'existe pas comment
ça se passe en pologne est ce que vous
avez eu vent de ce genre de choses
encore
j'aurais président du parlement pour
deux ans nous n'avons jamais les actes
de ce type ne s'est pas libéré vous ne
pouvez pas nous dire ici que ça se passe
je pense que partout il faut faire tous
pour le protégea de femmes
vous savez la parole s'est libérée en
même temps la parole n'était pas
complètement fermé il ya ce cas c'est
que là les des événements médiatiques en
donner un espace où peut-être on a été
plus à l'écouté de ce qui se passe est
heureux mais j'imagine ce furent deux
procès à qui que ce soit que ça existe
dans d'autres parlements nationaux et
effectivement le parlement européen a au
moins le mérite d'avoir une structure
qui existe certes elle est perfectible
certes il faut l'améliorer mais mais ça
n'existe nulle part ailleurs donc ça
démontre que nous avons le souci
effectivement deux protéger les
personnes qui sont victimes de ces
agressions
alors il ya une résolution qui a été
voté largement au parlement lors de la
dernière session
typiquement c'est très symbolique une
résolution
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire concrètement
marek urech pour changer les choses sur
ces questions de harcèlement
hormis saisir la justice est-ce qui a
pas quelque chose de plus large à faire
autour des questions d'éducation à 7 à
cette question dans le plan concrètes il
fort je ne peux pas encore fois
responsabiliser responsabilisait de
personnes qui commis ces actes donc
responsabilité pénale est nécessaire
nous devons revenir de vert +2 respecte
pour des femmes pour sexualité pour des
relations intimes
vous êtes d'accord est-ce qu'il faut
évidemment qu'il faut responsabiliser
mais malheureusement ça ne suffit pas
les très mal l être humain il est ainsi
fait il a besoin d'avoir des règles des
normes
il faut qu'ils sachent mais est-ce que
l'aloe suffira non la loi ne suffira pas
mais d'abord des gens entre nous le fait
de dire là ce qui s'est passé vous savez
ça ça ça quand même ébranlés mais ils
ont bien compris l'heure c'est l'heure
tout le monde chante tout le monde
attend les noms mais quand vous dites
une résolution symbolique non c'est plus
que cela
ça continue c'est à dire que l'audit
externe on va la voir en val mandaté
avec une lettre de mission bien précise
le fait effectivement de mettre en place
un comité spécial harcèlement sexuel
parce que ils sont composés par dont
deux professionnels de la médecine de
psychologues d'avocats de juges papa de
jute pardon d'avocats qui peuvent
effectivement conseillé et protéger la
victime ça j'ai ça changera les j'espère
que ça prendra forme ça changera les
choses c'est à dire que ici j'espère
dans un futur très proche
chaque responsable chaque personne qu'il
soit député ou pas parce que vous savez
il n'ya pas que du harcèlement entre un
député sonata j'ai un pur c'est dans les
administrations et qu' ils sauront que
dorénavant il va une instance qui pourra
inscrire le dossier ça pour aller en
justice
et ça pour aller très loin évidemment au
pénal de toute façon nous suivrons à ces
questions direction maintenant la
hongrie depuis des années viktor orban
n'en finit plus de dériver vers un
régime autoritaire référendum stop
bruxelles chasse aux migrants mur à la
frontière fermeture d'université et mise
au pas de la presse et des ong
des exemples ne manquent pas et inquiète
ses voisins européens c'est un reportage
de flora sauvage
[Musique]
dans ce gymnase de szeged à 10 km de la
frontière serbe
l'entraînement a démarré à l'aube
chasseurs frontaliers c'est le nom
officiel d'un nouveau corps de la police
hongroise
objectif numéro 1 du gouvernement de
viktor orban
la chasse aux migrants
[Applaudissements]
cours d'autodéfense maniement des armes
et techniques d'arrestation sont au
programme
kitty était vendeuse dans une
boulangerie avant de se porter
volontaires à l'issue de sa formation de
six mois
elle ira assister les quelque dix mille
policiers et militaires déjà déployés à
la frontière
financièrement c'est beaucoup plus
intéressant que mon ancien travail mais
c'est aussi plus stable en tant
qu'apprenti je gagne l'équivalent de 470
euros sans compter les primes quand je
travaillais en boulangerie je gagnais
330 euros environ l'interview de kitty
se fait sous le contrôle de sa
hiérarchie
aucune question politique n'est autorisé
bonjour à tous
force et performances repos prenez place
l'objectif de la police nationale est de
recruter trois mille chasseurs
frontaliers pour atteindre ce chiffre
la police nationale mobilise les polices
régionales ce sont elles qui assurent le
recrutement et la formation des
candidats remplissant les critères
l'objectif final est de garantir un
meilleur maintien de l'ordre et apporter
plus de sécurité au pays et pour
empêcher les migrants de traverser la
hongrie le gouvernement a érigé une
clôture le long de la frontière avec la
serbie et la croatie
longue de 175 km équipée de caméras
elle a coûté près de 900 millions
d'euros un coût amplement justifiée
selon ce membre fondateur du fides le
parti du premier ministre viktor orban
on a pu voir en europe de l'ouest ce qui
est arrivé ces deux trois dernières
années la plupart des terroristes sont
des migrants c'est une évidence
il n'y a pas de débat à ce sujet
bruxelles est chargé de répartir les
migrants dans tous les pays mais ils ne
prennent pas en compte les conséquences
que cela va avoir pour l'europe
d'autre part il ne fixe pas de limite à
l'accueil des réfugiés
est ce que ce sera un million de
migrants par an 10 millions en deux ans
cinq ans six ans un point de vue sur les
migrants qui n'est pas partagé par tous
vous pensez vraiment que la question des
migrants c'est la question la plus
importante aujourd'hui en hongrie
la hongrie se vante d'avoir grâce
tiquement diminuer le nombre de
demandeurs d'asile grâce à sa clôture
anti migrants persona non grata sur le
territoire maillard ahmed h en a fait
l'amère expérience ce syrien a été
condamné à dix ans de prison pour avoir
tenté de franchir la frontière en 2015
accusé de terrorisme
après avoir lancé trois pierres sur la
police qui empêchait les migrants de
passer il a fait appel de la décision
le tribunal se réunit donc une nouvelle
fois ma question est de savoir si
l'accusé reconnaît les faits qui lui
sont reprochés
je tiens à le dire en toute transparence
je rejette formellement ces accusations
en hongrie le système judiciaire est
sous la coupe du pouvoir exécutif
juste après les émeutes qui ont éclaté
en 2015 à la frontière serbo-croate
tous les politiciens hongrois ont
condamné ahmed h et l'on qualifié de
terroriste donc il est tout à fait
évident qu'il y avait une grande
pression politique sur la procédure et
sur la cour
autre cible du gouvernement les ong une
loi les oblige désormais à déclarer
toutes leurs ressources financières
venant de l'étranger
les noms des donateurs seront listés sur
un site publié par l'exécutif une loi
qui n'est pas sans conséquence amnesty
international n'accepte pas de dons
provenant des états donc nous dépendons
largement de petits dons individuels et
nous constatons que certains donateurs
ont désormais peur de donner pour ne pas
entrer en conflit avec le gouvernement
hongrois
l'idée principale qui régit la proche du
gouvernement c'est que tous ceux qui
n'entrent pas dans la droite ligne du
gouvernement et contre l'intérêt de la
nation des journalistes indépendants
sont aussi dans le collimateur du victor
ban une loi oblige les médias à
s'enregistrer auprès des autorités et à
produire des sujets équilibré le
gouvernement s'attaque également à
l'enseignement supérieur à travers
l'université d'europe centrale qu'il
veut fermer à six mois des prochaines
élections la dérive autoritaire du
premier ministre hongrois ne semble pas
prête de s'arrêter
[Musique]
marc a cure et qu'est-ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter que cette dérive autoritaire
de la hongrie je pense que ça ne parte à
châtel complètement partisans artisans
parce qu'il ne représente pas de
sensibilité de la société angoua qui
plusieurs fois à est lui le gouvernement
actuel de viktor orban lier la carte
fois quatrième fois premier ministre et
un gouvernement qui a été le premier
ministre parce que les gouvernants du
gouvernement précédent a menti la
société où la situation économique est à
la sorbonne à moderniser l'économie
il protège la frontière je pense que
tout le monde nous dit et c'est
d'ailleurs aussi de l'eau en pologne
nous avons été élus démocratiquement
pour appliquer en fait ce type de
programme donc
après tout en demandant aux électeurs
c'est ça que vous voulez dire du
seulement je ne dis pas bien sûr chaque
voie démocratique doit agir dans le
cadre des règles juridiques s'assure ça
le principal
est ce que la terre des droits n'est je
pense qu'il faut écouter de cinq lois
pourquoi il préfère le gouvernement
durban orban landry actuellement c'est
l'état de droit
ce n'était pas le cas des gouvernements
précédents
edouard martin et moi je suis toujours
effaré d'entendre toujours la même
argumentation qui est certes est vrai
ils ont été élus démocratiquement
je veux je veux pas vous faire l'affront
de vous rappeler qu hitler aussi avec
des vues démocratiquement et on a vu ce
que ça a donné
mais évidemment vous avez raison il faut
écouter les électeurs hongrois mais le
devoir
notre devoir en tant qu'élu européen et
les institutions européennes
c'est aussi de rappeler or ban quelles
sont les règles européennes et quelles
sont les conditions les critères
d'adhésion et les critères de copenhague
samba flou au pied tous les jours marc
hörmann donc il faudra aussi puisque ce
sont des grands démocrates des électeurs
hongrois ont aussi leur expliquer que
nous sommes aussi des démocrates et que
nous voulons que nos règles que nous
avons voté ensemble elles soient
respectés or or bahn ne les respectent
pas et ça sera le choix de la hongrie
de dire eh bien l'europe et nous
convient aux restos c'est l'union
européenne ou bien les règles
européennes ne nous conviennent pas et
on vous dit au revoir
il ya aucun problème et que nous avons
complètement de figure
alors alors je le problème est remise au
pas de la presse des organisations non
gouvernementales
une université qui est financé soit
disant par l'étranger qui la ferme et
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ça je
le garde
madame je regarde la discussion sur la
loi universitaires en france depuis ma
première visite dans 1988 tendent à la
réforme des vainqueurs en france il y
avait aussi beaucoup de protest ne
partagent même l'opposition
là on devait de 20,86 était la sélection
à l'unité oz après il y avait beaucoup
des prothèses donc je pense que les
controverses démocratiques sont tout à
fait légitimes dans les problèmes de
l'université de surrey en hongrie qu'il
faut respecter la loi hongroise qu'il
faut agir dans le cadre de luangwa parce
que malheureusement nos états de
l'europe centrale
après la libération du communisme était
subordonnée souvent aux règles nord
coloniale que par exemple les
institutions étrangères ne doit pas
respecté la loi de pays
ce n'était pas acceptable dans aucune
faillite je pense que france jamet
n'acceptera telle situation
sidéré et c'est également le cas en
pologne donc vous êtes élu je rappelle
que vous avez été aussi vice-président
du parti droit et justice 2002 à 2007
avant de le quitter
parti droit et justice qui est également
dans le collimateur de bruxelles sur ces
questions vous estimez en fait que les
lois
les chartes qui sont décidées à
bruxelles sont un diktat au même titre
que ça pouvait l'être
je voudrais jeunes communistes je pense
que cela que la manifestation d'un sac à
nos 10 ans ce que nous nommons ici au
parlement européen la justice sélective
simplement qu'il ya des droits le droit
national
ils peuvent le poker de loi mais de
l'oise si le peuple polonais de
recherche de l'eau à juin villeréal bali
où le peuple hongrois dans sa majorité
estime que nous autres européens
nous vous imposons un diktat fait comme
la grande bretagne fait un référendum et
quitte l'europe ne vous convient pas
alors vous justifier l'appellation de
liberté de parole alors dernière
question on entend beaucoup en fait
dire que potentiellement l'europe serait
prête à mettre sur la table
l'article 7 c'est à dire la privation
des droits de vote pour la pologne où
pour la hongrie dans le cadre en fait
justement de ces problématiques de
droits fondamentaux
j'imagine que vous n'êtes pas d'accord
avec ça mais là où pour le coup la
pologne et la hongrie ont de la chance
c'est que l'article 7 doit être votée à
l'unanimité c'est à dire y compris avec
les voix de la pologne et de la hongrie
ça n'arrivera donc jamais donc comment
est-ce qu'on peut recréer le dialogue
marek cech entre l'union européenne et
les pays de l'est et respectant
mutuellement parents ne s'agit sûrement
parce que je pense que beaucoup de pays
dominants dans l'union européenne ne
comprennent pas via de la situation des
pays d'europe centrale
nous devons reconstruire nos pays à près
d'un demi siècle de dictatures
totalitaires et de domination étrangère
nous avons un autre escalier elle refuse
aidé à reconstruire le pays
donc l'europe vous aident à reconstruire
vos pays monsieur là pourvoyeur de fonds
nationaux dont vous aider à vous
construire donc la solidarité européenne
joue à plein vis-à-vis notamment de la
pologne sa valise noire
vous n'avez pas vous n'avez pas la
discussion
non mais si vous quittez une émeute à
entendre les enfants excusez-moi
solidarnosc qui a garanti à l'europe la
sécurité si vous avez moins besoin aussi
de la défense aujourd'hui c'est grâce à
sécurité de l'europe après libération de
vous et tout ça grâce une question
est-ce que même dans le sang le
président de france a déposé la gerbe
sur la tombe de lénine
oui ou non leurs hôtes vous aide à vous
reconstruire financièrement est ce que
oui ou non on vous aide
comment vous en mars nous payons nous
payons non non vous êtes du oui ou non
répondre à ma question c'est quelle
europe sas a largement le niveau pas la
couleur
vous contestez que la france applique
grand export
ap
on va pas refaire l'histoire derniers
mois doit martin est ce que vous vous
seriez favorable à l'application de cet
article 7 sur le droit de vote
le pays qui évidemment parce que vous
aurez bien compris que c'est le chien
qui se mord la queue
ouais et c'est pas la hongrie qui va
voter contre elle-même bien si evans se
permet autant de dérives c'est parce que
justement le rock ne peut pas bruce ne
pas agir et comment recréer un dialogue
dans un respect mutuel femmes les plaies
des marins curé ben écoutez il faut
avoir des gens de bonne volonté de part
et d'autre je pense que on l'a invité à
plusieurs reprises à venir débattre en
lua bienvenue à chaque fois revenus à
chaillevois s'explique on a ici le lui
faire comprendre que c'est ça n'est pas
la façon de faire quand vous voulez le
dialogue et à chaque fois il retourne en
hongrie en faisant entre guillemets à
doigt d'honneur à l'europe je pense
qu'un an donné faut que ça s'arrête
bon bah écoute et or suivra en attendant
cette question merci à vous d'avoir
accepté de débattre merci beaucoup marek
cech mère meurt matin c'est la fin de
cette émission mais pas de panique vous
pouvez la revoir en replay et à l'envi
sur notre site internet
rendez vous la semaine prochaine avec
ahmed tazir depuis bruxelles nantes
strasbourg la semaine prochaine depuis
strasbourg très belle semaine à tous
[Musique]